welcome to the daily climate show stay
with us coming up how will germany keep
warm in winter after russia slashes
crucial gas supplies
floods heat waves and wildfires extreme
weather across the u.s continues as the
country feels the impact of climate
change
[Music]
and why cats have been declared an
invasive species in poland
[Music]
welcome to the daily climate show where
we track the changes happening to our
world hear from those affected and
report on the race for solutions now
energy prices in the uk could reach
nearly 4
000 pounds a year after russia curbed
gas supplies to europe the warning from
utilities consultancy bfy comes as eu
countries move to reduce their reliance
on russian gas so after gazprom halved
gas supplies to europe in germany
in germany russia has been cutting flows
to the country with it now operating at
less than a fifth of its normal capacity
the move which russia says is due to
pipeline maintenance is being seen as
further escalation of an energy standoff
between moscow and the european union
that will make it harder and costlier
for the bloc to fill up storage ahead of
the winter heating season
well we can talk now to our europe
correspondent adam parsons who is in
cologne adam thanks for joining us it's
a really tricky time for germany isn't
it because
not least because they are switching off
their nuclear power plants by the end of
the year
exactly right they have found themselves
in something of a of a bind here you
have to go back over quite a few years
of german energy policy and it's not
pretty reading and a yep they they
absolutely said angela merkel said we
are getting rid of nuclear power after
the fukushima uh disaster and they're
pressing on with that
trouble is they've also been very
reliant on russian gas well that turned
out to be a bad idea remember they built
nordstrom 2 that pipeline that was never
opened
and of course they are still using a lot
of coal not just any old coal but
lignite really dirty uh grubby cult so
that's the energy mix they find
themselves in at the moment uh the other
bit of that was nordstrom the original
nordstrom one pipeline that connects
germany to russia and that is the one
that gazprom is now dialing down there
are those who think that eventually
gazprom might switch that one off
entirely and germany is in a bit of a
panic because it relies on that russian
gas yes he's trying to find other ways
of filling the gap of investing in
renewable energy and trying to get oil
and gas from other countries but the
bottom line is it hasn't plugged the gap
yes so it is nervously watching that
north stream pipeline and seeing uh
about the flows but at the same time
it's trying to find ways of reducing the
use
of energy and that's what brings us to
places like uh cologne where a raft of
measures are being brought in street
lamps are being dimmed at night for
instance swimming pools are not being
heated in the way that they normally
would be we've been out to see a housing
estate where now the thermometer is
being turned down the heating is not
going to rise as high as it had done
previously now clearly if you live in a
place like that a you might be annoyed
at the heating and b we spoke to plenty
people who say they're worried about
uncertainty about what comes next but
what is likely is higher bills in
germany as anywhere else lots of
pressure
on the government to do something about
it maybe as in britain pressure to strip
away some of those green levels now
remember the green party here is part of
the coalition today we had confirmation
that 25 billion euros was going to be
put into a climate fund they have talked
a good game about embracing
environmentalism but they did that
before this huge looming energy crisis
adam parsons in cologne in germany for
us thanks very much for that
now environmental campaigners say much
more time needs to be given to the
climate crisis in the tory leadership
contest organizations including the
world wildlife fund greenpeace and the
green alliance are calling for the
candidates to be better tested on their
climate credentials it comes as business
secretary quasi qatang who's backing
this trust says climate issues are being
taken seriously after the u.s climate
envoy john kerry warned the leadership
hopefuls not to [ __ ] with net zero
plans by slashing green levees
we've got energy prices that have gone
through the roof they're global it's a
global issue
uh gas prices have gone through the roof
we've got russia invading ukraine we've
got russia threatening to turn off the
gas supply to large parts of western
europe and in that context this trust is
saying we've got to look at the energy
mix we've got to look at the costs
and we may have to suspend green levees
as a consequence because this is an
extraordinary time
let's bring in our political
correspondent ali fortescue ali what do
we know about the tory hopefuls climate
credential so far what's been discussed
well it is right that their climate
credentials have not been front and
center of this campaign so far what has
been front and center is the economy
that's been the big dividing line there
have over the last couple of days in the
tv debates we've had been a couple of
questions about climate change rishi
sunak has been talking about things like
technology the need to insulate homes
there's trust has been talking about
food waste but really i think there is
pressure
on them for there to be more more
commitments and more clarity on how they
want to tackle climate change what we do
know is that they are both talking about
the cost of living crisis on that liz
trust says that she wants to suspend
green levees you heard her back at quasi
quatern talking about it there on energy
bills that though is obviously we know
green levees is all about helping the
transition toward clean energy so there
have been criticisms that she is not
someone that is committed to net zero
she says she is but we need to find
different ways of getting there but at
the moment as i say i think there is
definitely pressure on to her to show
how exactly she's going to be doing that
rishi sunak he um overnight has been
talking about cutting vat on energy
bills it's been criticized as a u-turn
because he previously
was criticizing labor when they
suggested a similar policy but today the
ifs a warning that maybe that will have
an impact too because could that drive
up energy use so there are questions
when it comes to their climate
commitments and what they are saying
about how they plan to solve the big
issue of the cost of living crisis um
but they do say that they do have
commitments and that they are going to
be talking about it more but i think all
eyes will be on the next few debates and
the hustings to see whether they really
can deliver something on climate change
we will watch with interest ally
fortitude in westminster for us thanks
for that
now let's get a bit more of today's
climate news the isla isle of man has
become the first place in the uk to see
a hosepipe ban enforced the restrictions
come into force at midnight on friday
and after an unusually dry spring which
was followed by a 50 drop in average
rainfall in june anyone caught flouting
the hosepipe ban could be fined up to
2000 pounds
japan's industry minister koichi
hagayuda has been made the country's
first ever green transformation minister
the new position has been created as
part of the government's plans to
achieve carbon neutrality by 2050
through changes to its economic and
energy structures it comes as japan's
administration holds its first meeting
today planning green transformation
policies
domestic cats have been labeled an
invasive alien species by a polish
scientific institute it follows a
growing scientific consensus that
felines damage birds and wildlife
because of the numbers they hunt and
kill domestic cats were added to the
database already containing more than
1700 species
now with destructive fires flooding and
intense heat so far it's been a week of
extreme weather in the u.s
at least one person has died after
record-breaking rain caused flash
flooding in the city of saint louis the
body was found covered in more than
eight feet of water
dozens were rescued after 30 centimeters
of rain destroyed homes and submerged
cars in the area
more than 36 million people across the
u.s are living under extreme heat
advisories watches or warnings parts of
oregon and washington state have
excessive heat warnings with
temperatures expected to reach 37
degrees in the city of portland where
the state's mayor has declared a state
of emergency
more than 500 wildfires are burning in
the northern state of alaska millions of
acres have burned there after recent
heat waves droughts and lightning
strikes started blazes
firefighters are continuing to battle a
huge wildfire in mariposa county near
yosemite national park in california
more than 2 000 firefighters have been
at the site since it started on friday
around 6 000 residents have been
evacuated sky's joe pike sent the latest
from there
it is the complete lack of color that is
most striking here it's a grey landscape
the trees have been stripped bare of
leaves and it's almost silent
there is no bird song
we pretty regularly though hear the
sounds of helicopters flying overhead
dropping retardant
over the flames there are many different
factors that contribute to wildfires
including the intense drought in this
state low humidity high heat dry parched
vegetation but if you speak to
firefighters who've been dealing with
these sorts of emergencies over decades
they say they've sensed a shift
we are having
rapid growth of fires extreme fire
behavior that we normally don't see
until later in the fire season in
september and october we expect
most fires to grow very rapidly
and with that it will also deplete
resources so we'll be
we'll be shorter on resources for some
fires and we we definitely expect to be
busy
california's wildfire season will
continue into the summer and through to
the autumn it's likely to get more
intense as time passes and the resources
of the fire services then could really
be
under pressure of course the residents
who call this area home who have
family and friends here face a difficult
choice especially those whose homes have
been destroyed do they try and leave and
start a new life elsewhere or do they
try and rebuild knowing that all of this
could happen again
kew gardens has secured a multi-million
pound investment to help fund its
research into climate change and how to
solve the global food crisis the funding
from greensphere capital will help pay
for extra researchers who will look into
climate change resistant crops
zero carbon fertilizer and plant and
cell-based meat products
well as it happens we'll be visiting kew
gardens later in the week where tom heap
will be taking a look at how we need to
adapt our gardening habits to the
changing climate and tom can put your
questions to an expert just stand the qr
code on your screen right now to submit
a question and we'll do our best to give
you an answer on the climate show with
tom heap on saturday and sunday at 3 30
and 7 30 p.m that is all from us today
thanks very much for watching we'll see
you soon